here now with reaction I think they
might have some our Fox News
contributors Leo Terrell and Miranda
Devine Miranda thank you for joining me
tonight you've of course you the New
York Post on top of really own the this
Hunter Biden story it was so threatening
that the you know it was stopped by the
FBI with social media it was damaging
and we now know after the election that
is a single digit percentage it was
maybe six or seven percent I think a
Biden voter said that would have
affected their vote if they had known
but isn't this also about character
about the nature of who people are which
then informs how they look and view us
if you're going to ignore your seventh
grandchild as like a non-entity what do
you what do you think they think of all
of us strangers who aren't even related
to them
look that's a quite an insightful point
there Tammy because I think what we've
seen with Joe Biden as a politician is
that he's built for half a century this
mythology around himself which is a sort
of modeled on the Kennedy Clan and it is
that he's a devout Catholic and a family
man and that families everything to him
and I think you know there are lots of
uh holes in that mythology now we've
seen who he really is we've seen his
character
um and it's not just in the sort of be
his involvement and lying about his
involvement in his family's influence
peddling scheme but it's also in these
small glimpses we have into his actual
family life and I think the fact that he
and Jill Biden ignore their seventh
grandchild I mean I know she was born in
a different circumstances and uh you
know Hunter claimed he couldn't remember
the relationship with the mother even
though it went on for several months I
think the little girl deserves some sort
of acknowledgment
she did certainly she deserves better
the country deserves better when it
comes to role models Leo you know we've
got a dynamic and we get caught up as
people who care about politics and
everything but really it's about
individual people that we vote for Who
present themselves in a certain way and
we find we see it with Gavin Newsom we
see it with really everybody and that's
frankly I think in part why Trump has
been so appealing you know we've known
him all the good and the bad and that
alone was kind of shocking that you knew
who you had and and to this day he's the
same guy for all of what matters to us
when it comes to policy
isn't this just shocking not just on the
political end but because of the nature
I'm I'm the product of an affair every
person born matters and of course the
argument for the pro-life Community is
before you're born you matter as well
doesn't this kind of show you everyone
the hypocrisy and the lies that really
imbue this entire family
absolutely you know Joe Biden does have
a moral compass Tammy he loves power
control that's why he's been a
politician for 50 years and he's placed
a criminal misconduct of his son over
the interest of the American people
100 byte is a political liability a
moral liability to this country and yet
Joe Biden has used the power of the
federal government to protect the Sun
not to protect the American people but
to protect his son and you know what you
got 95 thank goodness for Miranda but
you got 95 percent of the left-wing
media protecting Joe Biden and the
misconduct of his son Tammy Miranda if
Hunter by name was Trump he'd be facing
a multitude of felony charges and
hundreds of years in jail but hunter
Biden has high power attorneys and I'll
tell you one final point the Crim the
current impeachment trials potentially
against Biden against Merrick Garland
against Christopher Ray is in part due
to Hunter Biden's misconduct and Joe
Biden's never in the attempt to cover up
for his son yeah Leo the excellent
points in Miranda you know people say oh
it's just kind of him supporting Hunter
is what you know makes him a great dad
wouldn't that have been the case to
before all of this happened and that you
weren't engaging with deals with China
or allegedly so with your son who now
argues that he was too high on crack to
know what he was doing isn't that where
a Father's Love first comes in and even
supporting your son without having him
be in front with the American people
isn't that where that is supposed to
work
look I have no doubt that Joe Biden does
love his son and you know any parent
wants to protect their child but in in
Joe Biden's case I think uh you have to
really question a father who puts his
addicted son in front of all this
unaccountable cash he made Hunter The
Bag Man for the family he knew what was
going on
himself has admitted that it was the
money from barisma the 83 000 a month
that was flooding in that was too much
of a Temptation for him and he fell off
the wagon
um you know he struggled in his life and
I think most Americans would wish him
the best in his recovery but I think
that Joe Biden has really perverted uh
the course of Justice when it comes to
the FBI the CIA and the federal
government yes a great Point all because
of character and the lack thereof Leo
Miranda thank you very much now i up
next hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else